on the eleventh day of Christmas we have
element number eleven sodium not a piece
of sodium a tile with sodium on it and
sodium is element number eleven and it
really is a tile look on the back it was
made by an Italian school girl called
Sofia who was brought here by her father
Leonardo plus a school friend and other
family members she's a real periodic
videos fan and she wanted to come for
her birthday to Nottingham and she made
this tile for me
so I could put my mug on top of it and
the reason why she chose sodium is
because she saw in a video as sodium
video that I said that sodium was my
favorite element holy crap not because
it explodes but because my mother's
first name her Christian name was inna i
na and there's a little girl she used to
call herself na and my children used to
call their grandmother now because of
this so every time I see the symbol na
na I gets us a warm motherly feeling and
Sophia like this and made me a great
tile so I have it on my desk
and I brought it down here specially for
the 11th day so number 11 tile with
sodium two elements osmium and thorium
periodic table handkerchief charts beam
from our carbon lab fan from a fan
and six-carbon blowing plectrum for
guitar for drinking vessels three
chemical badges two periodic table bed
covers and one piece of tartaric acid
from a Swiss wine barrel let's see what
we have for day 12
tiny droplets of metallic sodium and as
these droplets go through the air
some of them will react with the water
vapor in the air and some will react
with the oxygen in the air there's a lot
more oxygen than water